in this video we'll be talking about
Chiari malformation this is one type of
brain malformation where the cerebellum
gets displaced downward through the
foramen of the Magnum into the upper
spinal canal
and this kind of malformation could lead
to severe problems this is how a normal
individual's brain look like here is a
skull cerebellum brain stem spinal cord
and here is the foramen of Magnum in
case of chiary malformation the
cerebellum descends down the cerebellar
tonsil actually descends down through
the foramen of Magnum to the upper
spinal canal if we zoom into this
situation we can understand the
descended cerebellum might create extra
pressure on the brain stem
as well as there could be blockage of
the normal cerebrospinal fluid flow that
might result in obstructive
hydrocephalus there could be different
types of chiary malformation type 1
which is the most common type and
usually present during the type of birth
so it's congenital
there could be type 2 also known as
Arnold Theory malformation and it's
often associated with myeloma
meningocele that means which is also a
distinct feature in spina bifida
there are other types like type 3 and
type 4 which are less common
so let's talk about the different
classification in bit more detail so
this is how the normal Trend look like
this is the type 1 Kia email formation
and this is type 2. type 2 is often
associated with uh
hydrocephaly and type 1 leads to a
downward disen of the cerebellar tonsil
but type 2 not only as gets associated
with hydrocephalus but also there is a
downward displacement of the cerebellum
brain stem as well as the fourth
ventricle this leads to our obstruction
in the CSF flow which is ultimately
leading to the hydrocephalus
when it comes to symptoms it could be
headaches that often
worse with the cuffing or straining then
there are neck pain nausea vomiting like
situations balance and coordination
problem dizziness muscle weakness vision
and hearing disturbances fine motor
skill problems and ultimately sometimes
in difficulty in swallowing or speaking
symptoms can vary
So based on individual to individual but
some of the symptoms are pretty common
diagnosis can be done using magnetic
resonance imaging MRI can reveal the
extent of cerebellar tonsil descent or
herniation through the spinal canal
so this is a MRI finding you can see in
Chiari malformation
the cerebellar tonsil has descended down
and it is clearly visible on A sagittal
section
in kiary malformation type 2 the
distinct features include cerebellar
tonsils the intercerebellum and the
brain stem has descended down
so the herniation is pretty clear also
it is associated with
myelomeningosil which is a pretty
distinct feature of Chiari malformation
type 2.
Theory malformation can happen in with
happen to any individual from any
ethnicity but it has been seen the
prevalence is somewhat more in the
females the reason behind that is not
really known but people think there is a
genetic component associated with it
when it comes to treatment it can be
treated or the symptoms can be managed
with physiotherapy pain medications and
sometimes surgery is required for
extreme cases
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up you
can get more notes and flashcards in our
Instagram and Facebook page support us
using super thanks see you in next video
foreign